one of the leading scientific
achievements of this decade is that the
American male may now dream in
Technicolor in fact there are men who
refuse to dream in black and white at
all anymore
one of the most recent reasons for this
is miss Arlene Dahl who will confer the
awards for the best achievement in art
direction ladies and gentlemen Miss Dahl
thank you for the best achievement in
art direction of a black-and-white
production the following pictures were
nominated hamlet J Arthur rank Two
Cities film universal international
British Roger K first set Direction calm
and Dylan Johnny Belinda Warner Brothers
Robert M Haas set Direction William
Wallace Roger cave first for Hamlet J
Arthur rank Two Cities there
mr. William Gordon will accept the award
for the winner and for the step
direction on the same picture column
Dylan
mr. Gordon will also accept the award
mr. Gordon again for the best
achievement in art direction of a color
production are the following Joan of Arc
Sierra pictures RKO radio Richard de set
direction Casey Roberts and Joseph Kish
the red shoes J Arthur rank archers
eagle lion british hein heck roth second
set decoration arthur Lawson hi Nick
Roth for the red shoes Jacob
miss Susan Hayward will accept the award
for the winner also for set decoration
of the Lawson miss Susan Hayward will
also accept his award thank you thank
you very much miss doll